día de países latinoamericanos en la cop
27 con más de una decena de ministros
hablando y a pesar de las diferencias
ideológicas hubo un llamado al unísono
exigirle a los países más desarrollados
que cumplan con la financiación para
combatir la crisis climática por ejemplo
Argentina y Nicaragua recordaron que es
necesario que los más industrializados
cumplan su promesa de dar 100 mil
millones de dólares anuales a los más
vulnerables mientras que Ecuador pidió
que esto no sea a manera de deuda México
por su parte habló de indemnizaciones
para referirse al mecanismo de pérdidas
y daños indemnizaciones es una palabra
que los desarrollados prefieren evitar
para no abrir demandas legales mientras
que República Dominicana dijo que no se
trataba de Caridad sino de justicia y
que sin este mecanismo no habría un
acuerdo en charmershake Argentina
Ecuador y chile le pidieron a los más
desarrollados que más ambiciosos al
cumplir y al establecer sus metas
climáticas por su parte el ministro
brasileño Joaquín Pereira se concentró
en defender las labores del saliente
Yair bolsonaron al decir que sí son un
gobierno ambiental por producir
hidrógeno y amoniaco verde y al decir
que contrario a lo que hicieron
gobiernos pasados ellos no se dedicaron
a multar y a perseguir sino hacer
alianzas con los privados sin embargo no
mencionó que bajo el mandato de
bolsonaro la deforestación en la
amazonía aumentó un 73% según los datos
oficiales del inpe y todo esto ocurre A
pocas horas de que el presidente electo
Lula da Silva se pronuncie en la copa ya
habló con los enviados climáticos de
Estados Unidos y China y mañana se
reunirá con seis de los nueve
gobernadores amazónicos de Brasil y
también dará su discurso en el que se
espera que ponga a Brasil de nuevo en el
centro ambiental